c'est vraiment une partie seulement de
mon mon dossier médical
après des mois de délai engendrés par la
pandémie 26 mars au lait a entamé le 5
novembre son premier traitement
d'insémination être à utérine pour
tomber enceinte
c'est râlant trop peur ça comme ça au
québec la régie de l'assurance maladie
rembourse cette procédure dont le taux
de réussite varie entre 3 et 25%
notamment selon l'âge de la patiente
lorsqu'on leur médecin voit la patiente
habituellement on prescrit de faire
trois cycles d'insémination ok donc
trois traitements aux trois cycles
d'insémination avant de revoir le
médecin pour changer de traitement faire
de multiples modifications et tout mais
un cycle est vraiment c'est l'équivalent
de 3 22 novembre le premier essai a
échoué dans le 6 mars les contacts sa
clinique de fertilité pour en effectuer
un deuxième mais les règles du jeu ont
changé avec l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi 73 sur la procréation assistée
depuis le 15 novembre seules les femmes
de 41 ans moins un jour sont admissibles
à un remboursement d'un sim harcelé à 41
ans et 9 mois j'ai vendu à la elle
estime connaissait lustré entre 2100 et
2700 $ elle juge que les femmes de 41
ans et plus qui ont entamé leur
traitement avant le 15 novembre doivent
pouvoir compléter trois cycles
gratuitement comme c'était le cas avant
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi par
courriel le cabinet du ministre de la
santé et des services sociaux ou lionel
carmant répond qu'un groupe d'experts
avait été formé afin de guider notre
gouvernement quant au critère qui tenait
compte de la sécurité et de l'éthique
rappelons qu'un crédit d'impôt
disponible pour celles qui paient leur
traitement tous sont prêts pouvant
atteindre quand
courageuse sastre à cela au femmes qui
sont déjà dans un processus qui par sa
femme nancy marseillais ne perd pas
espoir même si ce changement à la loi
l'amène à revoir la façon dont elle
réalisera son rêve de devenir mère ici
valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal